so
[Music]
another wild week in the nfl it there's
no days off at this point it all leads
up to the nfl draft which is why we're
here live in the blue shirt report app
every thursday at 1 pm it's trap crash
course i'm connor rogers the lead nfl
draft analyst here at bleacher report
alongside as always the man from stadium
college football analyst michael felder
belder
it seems like every hour we gotta change
the rundown how are we feeling right now
man
feeling exhausted man we are busy busy
busy busy bees out here getting stuff
done but we're making it work and in the
nfl it's one of those things i love
about this is we're watching the draft
change before our eyes right the entire
complexion of the draft we're seeing
teams listen go from addressing needs in
free agency or trade so let's let's kick
it off with free agency right
yeah let's get right into it we're gonna
like you said we're gonna go through a
lot today we're gonna go through the
free agency moves to kick things off the
trades our divisional preview as always
it's the afc north which has been an
absolute battle and as always we're
going to do a positional preview which
is the edge rushers and i know that's
our favorite so we're really excited for
how we close out this show but let's get
things kicking with the most notable
signings of the week so far starting
with the minnesota vikings getting
sedaria smith a little change of heart
they're not going to the ravens they'll
pair him with the neil hunter you got
lyle collins the third big time veteran
addition for the cincinnati bengals at
this point you've got tyron armstead
going to the miami dolphins which boy
you watched them last year that
offensive line needs more than just him
but it's a really good start so felder
will kick things off with the vikings
we've gone through their 12th overall
pick a lot there's times where i've
thought edge rusher now we're looking at
it their parents at aria smith with the
neil hunter they got to be thinking
another direction how do you like this
fit and how do you like it for their
first round of the nfl trap
listen zadaria smith is a guy i mean
he's got 44 45 sacks and 90 games like
this
he's he gets the job done and that's
what you want you want a guy that can
get the job done so
a lot of times in the draft we talk
about players potential he doesn't have
potential he has actuality things that
he's actually done in the nfl so he
comes in and he already pencil him in
he's a starter you know pencil you write
it in pen he's going for it and i think
the adjustment for them is going to be
interesting i i think obviously we
mentioned lyle college to the bengals as
well
how do these teams recalibrate when you
talk about them making these moves
because
now the vikings have the freedom
to go get a guy that they're gonna have
for four maybe five years with the
option maybe it's a safety maybe it's
kyle hamilton if he drops down to them
maybe it's
you can look at a different position and
i think that's going to be an
interesting one and then obviously we
have to talk about lyle college to the
bengals they revamped that entire that
offensive line getting a bunch of guys
and
what does that mean for the broncos
because i think out of the end at the
end of all of this the broncos feel like
the team that we should talk about the
most because
we had them penciled in in the lyell
collins the lyle collins lottery and
they lost
you're all over it felder i think for
the broncos there they need a right
tackle right and they're not the only
team in that division that needs the
right tackle the raiders need one as
well and neither of those teams are
picking in the first round now so you're
looking more at the developmental range
i know we've talked about the broncos at
the end of round two maybe you get lucky
and a bernard raymond falls to you but
you're more in the field of you know max
mitchell is kind of the guy you're
looking at at this point so for the
broncos or a really interesting scenario
maybe darion canard who you and i think
is more of a guard at the next level
maybe you try to get by with him at
right tackle the position he played in
college for a long time so a lot to
unpack there but for the bengals to get
three veterans of course and you know
kappa uh ted karis and now lyell collins
that's a big time boost for joe burrow
and let's round this out with the miami
dolphins who have not just made the move
for tehran armstead to solidify the left
side of their offensive line but have
made all the headlines in the last 24
hours by acquiring tyreek hill now
of course this is all great for the
dolphins offense you've got one of the
best receivers in the nfl you got one of
the best left tackles in the nfl but
felder what you and i are more
interested in right now is the kansas
city chiefs and how they retool
this offense find the right wide
receiver for them with all of this extra
draft capital they have you see the
extra first rounder there they are now
picking in 29 and 30 of this nfl draft
and felder i kick things off here all
this extra draft capital how did they
package that and go up and essentially
try to replace tyree kill as hard as
that is and get jameson williams right
that's the player that i look at in this
situation you need speed that's what
patrick mahomes obviously is going to
thrive off with his ability to extend
plays throw the ball down the field you
look at jamison williams and you just
see the vertical speed that sub 4 3 kind
of burning over the top the ability to
win in between the 20s he does so many
things extremely extremely well
that it could completely get that
offense back to where it needs to be
right you're not going to once again
you're not going to replace tyreek hill
but kelsey jamison williams mahomes you
obviously make it maybe go out you got
juju smith schuster as your possession
guy they are in a good position to
retool and get younger at this wide
receiver group so number one what do you
think of the package to go up and get
james and williams is that the guy and
two do you have any other ideas in mind
i i like it i like the idea i think
jameson williams for me he's still the
best receiver in this draft even though
he's coming off an injury i think
garrett wilson fits into that as well i
think james williams has this um
deliberate this this this deliberate
nature with which he runs routes and
you're gonna see it here but he does
everything with purpose he is steady he
understands i have to push this guy wide
to get back inside he understands i have
to stem him to the inside to get back to
the outside i have to stem to the
outside to get to the inside i know
where the hole is in the zone as you see
right there this is where the space is
going to be for me to help my
quarterback out and look you see there
the little suddenness and the ability to
explode down the field and look he's not
running away from mcneese state right
he's not running away from
tulane he's running away from georgia so
the speed is for real and that's not a
joke you see there the stem inside to
get outside i love that but i'm gonna
tell you
i like the two for one and maybe that's
just the grocery shopper in me that
loves a bogo but i love it two for one
so i'm gonna say let's instead of
packaging let's keep 29 and 30. and you
know who we can get we can get jahan
datsun if we're the chiefs jahan dotson
a lot of the same suddenness not as
explosive not as fast but
he has the same intentionalness with his
route running that matters and i think
that's the incredible part here you're
gonna see him catch the ball outside of
his frame i love this play i put this
play on the reel that i did for stadium
because i was like this is one of my
favorite plays out of the entire season
his ability to know that he can't climb
too high can't go too low make himself
an option and then obviously you see
there that suddenness after the catch
the ability to run i think jahan dotson
at 29 or 30 becomes a quality pick this
guy is a space eater he finds ways to
create his own space and be open look at
this that route is beautiful
makes you think he's going here makes
the other guy think he's cleared and all
of a sudden he's wide open he gets
maryland to go make a play so i love
jahan dots and i think that he's someone
we should be talking about a little bit
more in one of these top tiers of wide
receivers
i love it felder and i i like your
thought process there go get a guy or
stay and get a guy that you think can
give you similar production in a sense
so they get jahan datsun obviously in
that spot but they get to sit there and
add to a secondary that needs help it
doesn't matter if they sign justin reed
they still need corners maybe you take a
corner of 30 maybe you pair read with
the safety like lewis scene jaquan
brisker at 30 and you get to keep that
50th overall pick to get another starter
so the chiefs looking for the volume
route you can only have so many
superstars with the nfl salary cap i
like the thought process there a lot
okay let's take a look at some other
trades that we saw this week obviously
the titans uh getting robert woods for a
bargain at this point a sixth round pick
but they tried it with julio jones he
just wasn't available to practice very
often and of course when you're not
available to practice you can't play
very often so they get robert woods who
is coming off the acl injury but they
think can have a really really good
impact so felder i look at this team
right now you have aj brown you have
robert woods you do have some holes in
the offensive line and you're picking in
the top 30 of the draft are we
officially at the point where we're
wiping wide receiver off the board for
tennessee
yeah i think they have to go with that
all they got to address the offensive
line listen if you're going to roll
with what you have right now in terms of
your offensive weapons you have to find
ways to make them more successful one of
the best ways to make them more
successful is offensive line now at the
back end of the the at the back end of
the giraffe who are they going to get
right like what who do you can they get
a guy that can come in and be a starter
or are they going to have to get someone
that's a developmental player
i think it's going to be a little bit of
a mix of both right it might be a
situation where you can get trevor
penning right around that 26th overall
pick and you might have to deal with
some growing pains but he is eligible to
start in a sense where he's not a total
you know traffic cone out there he's not
a dumpster out there the guys are just
pushing into the pocket or running by in
a sense that he
brings that element to the run game that
they love they love guys that are
bullies in the run game for derek henry
that can allow the train get rolling
down the tracks the second level of the
field and you might at right tackle
might have to allocate a little bit more
extra help to him you might have to put
a tight end next to his hip you might
have to
tell the running back listen you're
going to be watching the right side more
often than you're not so the titans kind
of in that in-between situation there
but i like that they knocked this need
off the board and even in a bigger way
the raiders going to get devonta adams
this is the big one right here
obviously tyrek hill as well we saw two
top five wide receivers in the nfl
traded in just a week span this is a big
one first and second round picks
the raiders got an absolute superstar
that derek carr knows very very well
going back to their college days but
when you look at this felder it becomes
fascinating just like the chiefs a super
bowl contender they just moved their
number one wide receiver a guy that so
much of the offense was funneled through
so
you're not replacing him but how do you
make up for some of that production and
this is a little fun because they're
picking at 22 and 28 in this draft
yeah two picks again listen we we talked
about the glory of the t of the double
pick so i just for me i look at it and
again it's the same guys on the board
right i don't want to mean to recycle
the conversation but at the the second
one they have that can be jihad dots and
the first one they have that can you
know what it could be is chris allave
and i think crystal lobby is an
interesting one because i don't think
that he goes as high as williams i don't
think he goes as high as garrett wilson
i don't think he goes even maybe as high
as treylon berks but if you get a lave
maybe you get a guy that does all this
stuff that aaron rodgers wants him to do
and that's a huge part of playing for
the gree bay packers is doing all the
stuff that aaron wants
and maybe that's olave because he can do
a lot of little things he does have um
he's got
big jordy nelson energy right like that
does that make sense saying that like a
guy that's i'll run this route i'll run
this route the way you like to run this
route this is how i'm gonna do this
route i'll do this route this way what
if i did it this way will that work for
you and i think he's got that energy so
i think that maybe that's in a lava
situation um you flip it over to the
raiders though and
is this one of those situations where
we're just we're listening to diddy like
for devonte adams waking back up with
car and it's like i'm coming home i'm
coming home tell the world i'm coming
home he's getting back to the west coast
like how how big is the impact you think
he's gonna have on that team
i think it's going to be huge and i
think you're in a division where
everybody's just throwing haymakers left
and right and you're trying to see who's
going to hit the mat first we obviously
saw the chargers come out uh and go get
khalil mack we obviously
see the chiefs going the draft route and
they have a lot of picks to get a lot
better and we saw the broncos go get
russell wilson i mean it's hard to leave
that one out of this so the raiders said
okay
we'll play the checkmate game as well
we're going to go get who we think is
the best wide receiver in the nfl which
is going to elevate our quarterback and
put more pressure on all of the
secondaries in this division so i
obviously love the move i think it's big
time for a team that needed a big time
wide receiver you weren't going to get a
player that was even 70 the caliber of
devante adams with that 20-second
overall pick so this is a win-now move
for a team that's made a big statement
going to vegas uh they need to put
people in the seats felder and it's a
it's a superstar splash
well here's the other the question i
will ask as someone that is former
defensive back at what point do they
start to address the secondaries
is it just let's see is it is is this
division just turning into
first team to 45 wins
like who because we saw them obviously
we see the jordan read but we saw tyra
matthew go we see
we see
secondary guys leaving
when do you address that part of it
that's something i know we didn't talk
about this before but as you as you
discussed
all the offensive loading up and we talk
about the russian loading up with khalil
mack
when do you address the secondary so
that maybe you can
stop someone
well it's funny to me felder everybody's
taking the same route of
we're going to all have two superstar
pass rushers so our front four gets home
and we think that's going to help out
the corners now we'll see if that comes
to fruition right they got chandler
jones they traded unique and gaque for
rakisson maybe they think rocky's in is
going to really settle in at the nfl
level that corner with them i think he's
been up and down with the colts early in
his career trevon merrick was a really
nice pick for them at safety last year
but those are that's one guy felder i
mean we we're watching these teams roll
out three weapons a piece so i'm with
you all the way let's dive into the
comments right now uh the first one from
b whoopee 2 who's the most consistent
dangerous pass rusher in your opinion
you're going to have to wait for that
because we're doing the edge rushers at
the end of the show today we can't wait
for that
we'll keep it rolling here a power user
mcat 93 says do the titans make a move
for wide receiver o-line in the first
round obviously we think offensive line
is in play for them and then alonso soto
felder i want to toss this one to you
because you started to touch on it and i
really like the fit you gave do the
packers
finally go wide receiver in the first
round this year
i mean with how much money they just
gave aaron rodgers they have to right
they have to and we hit on datsun we
talked about olave so they have to like
it's not
i don't i'm not the biggest aaron
rodgers fan but
i will say that at some point when you
invest this much into it
it's like it's like when you buy a
really nice car you're gonna have to go
to the car wash and that's what a wide
receiver is it's upkeep for the
quarterback that's the same thing with
offensive line you have to invest in
those things otherwise your really nice
investment is going to be wasted so
they've got to go i think they have to
go first round wide receiver don't you
yeah i think so too i think there's no
way around it i think it's not you can't
play the waiting game anymore and say oh
you know we'll we'll go get somebody on
day three and they'll be the new devante
adams because we have a 50 million
quarterback
i just don't think that's how this is
gonna go for them they need to go get a
difference maker weapon i did see in the
comments somebody gave uh mechi a shout
out i'm sorry that your name already
flew off the lower but i did like the
matchy shout out for day two of the
draft so we'll do one more question here
before we round out our opening segment
and get to uh some of the other big
quarterback trades which has just been
going on the entire offseason this one
from jay uh bernatowicz does it seem
impossible that a lobby is even there at
22 given there's a bunch of teams from
eight to 21 that need a wide receiver
should the packers trade up
see this is a tough one
i think it's entirely possible that a
lava is still there at 22
because
i i
i have no faith in the current nfl and
current gm's to not
be thirsty for quarterbacks and so
i think what we're like even as we rank
players and i know we we both go through
this system of ranking players and where
they sit at their position and we look
to the past to figure out where guys
would be like we like bleak willis
wouldn't be a top five quarterback if
this was a different draft but now he's
the number one quarterback so he's gonna
get picked in the top ten and then what
happens next is a team that needs a
quarterback can he pick it and we're
gonna see what happens with him and then
we're gonna see what happens with
desmond ritter which is another one so
all those things bump other people down
and i think that's the part of the draft
that we don't talk about nearly enough
is
how things get re-skewed and then it can
be the same thing with edge rushers
right where i mean we're literally and i
know we're going to talk about them
later but we're looking at a situation
where where maj sanders may end up being
at the end of the first round because
teams are going to go get these other
guys so i think that
positions like
edge rusher quarterback tackle can push
down
wide receiver obviously
my to my to much to my dismay safety and
change the complex change the way the
draft looks even though we have these
guys rated higher so i think olave being
there is not out of the question
i agree with you felder i think we do
this song and dance every year where we
go oh he's not going to be there he's
not going to be there and i always
remember how humbled i was when cd lam
was there at 17 and for me cd lamb i
thought was a top 10 player the best
wide receiver in that draft and then
he's sitting there at 17 and goes to a
team that already had two wide receivers
so you can't play the game of you know
and i like raising the question willie's
if he's not going to be there but you
always got to have a backup plan and
that's why you know felder you brought
up johan dotson earlier christian watson
is going to be in the picture as well
speaking of backup plans we're moving on
with the franchise quarterbacks that
have been moved and the colts got a
pretty good one honestly the falcons
trading away matt ryan
for the colts this was probably your
best possible outcome the carson wentz
experiment did not work you were not in
a position in this draft to go get one
of the top guys because you don't have a
first round pick so for matt ryan this
is probably a really good landing spot
for him to finish out his career go to a
team that's built to run the ball and
win now while belder we got to look on
the other side of this the falcons are
sitting there at eight and they only got
a third round pick back in this trade
but the falcons are sitting there with
the top ten selection they could be
staring in the face of malik willis or
kenny pickett is this a team
that needs to look for the future of
their franchise quarterback or are they
just gonna roll with marcus mariota to
kick this season off
this is interesting because mariota is a
guy that he's he had a huge flash when
he got into the league and then has kind
of very severely tapered off and i don't
know what he is anymore in the nfl
and then the the option is
with one they have to wait on what their
division mate does right the panthers if
the panthers at six are going to go
ahead and take malik willis then what do
they do they think can you pick it i
don't know
and so that becomes interesting because
if the panthers pass pass on willis then
maybe that is the guy they take and i
think that
there are these complexities to drafting
quarterbacks in the nfl into to picking
players in the nfl where malik willis
would i think be someone that a lot of
falcons fans would embrace it's like
they're
it's not i'm not going to sit here and
call it the second coming of vic but it
would certainly be
a person a personality and and a type of
quarterback that a lot of that fan base
would enjoy they want to get back to
right they've had they've had milk toast
matt ryan right and he's been very good
and he's been he's been good for them
got them to the super bowl didn't win it
but got him there
but
they do like the flash they do like that
dash they do like that that that that
ability to do things that are out of the
ordinary and malik willis can embody
that so i'm curious to see if he gets
past the panthers and then obviously
what they do
but for them they certainly are buyers
in the quarterback market and and i'll
ask you connor how long do you think you
have to wait if you're going to take
i'm not going to call him you know what
matt ryan 2.0 with a little more flair
in kenny pickett right like a guy that
plays in a pro-style offense
in college a guy that makes great
decisions a guy that's very safe with
the football he's more athletic than
matt ryan i will give him that for sure
obviously we saw the fake slide play um
but he's still a heady player how long
do you like could they trade back and
still get can he pick it
maybe i i think the the big wild card in
the room here felder is if
malik willis it shocks the world and he
goes two to the lions
are the panthers gonna force things and
say we need a guy because we're gonna
get fired with sam darnold we'll take
pickett at six let's live in a world
where that doesn't happen and we'll just
say malik willis is off the board at six
and pickett's sitting there it feels
like he makes a lot of sense for the
saints at 18. so i don't think you can
go beyond them but i do think you have
to be careful with where you go because
then teams can jump you we know the
steelers need a quarterback they got to
be in the hump for this thing they
obviously love malik willis but maybe
they like kenny pickett more than we're
led on to believe so i think when it
comes down to it you know the old saying
felder if you like a quarterback you
take them where you are and you just
roll with it and believe in them so
moving on to the cleveland browns here
who acquired desean watson obviously a
massive blockbuster trade as you see all
of the draft capital given up
i want to look at the texans here in
this spot because now they are picking
twice in the top 15. they join the jets
who are doing that they join the giants
who are doing that so a pretty crazy
turn of events here for houston who gets
a massive haul for deshaun watson i
think everybody's asking how are they
going to build this football team that
needs so much help and i look at the
number three pickfelder and i'm hearing
a lot of buzz around trayvon walker the
georgia front seven defender hand in the
dirt kind of a defensive man kind of can
play inside a powerhouse defender that i
admittedly do not think has a pass rush
plan here yet but with the
legendary testing obviously the built in
a lab kind of build and the flashes of
power on film
this is a team that is gonna build
things the inside out in my opinion and
when you look at nick casario who spent
most of his adult life in new england
and was around there when they had a guy
named richard seymour he might be
looking at trayvon walker and saying we
need a big tone setting bully up front
that i think can get even better than
what we've seen it would not shock me if
he goes third overall in this trap which
is a meteoric rise for trayvon walker
dude that's
we're going to talk about it later i
know we're going to talk edge rusher so
stick around folks we're going to talk
edge rushers later that is wild buck
wild to me
makes sense not calling you crazy i am
saying that that is insane because
realistically if we talk about that
georgia defense
trayvon walker is like
the fifth guy that we bring up usually
so it's nuts to think that he could go
in the top five but i i think if you're
the texans i think that you're you're
heavy they've got they've got two of
those two first two picks in the first
round they become another buyer in the
quarterback market what are they going
to do how how do they want to handle
this i think is interesting because
obviously
you've shipped away what was going to be
your franchise quarterback due to some
off due to his due to some due to his
off the field issues and now they're
looking at what are we going to be now
we don't we we've we've got new staff
we've got and we're trying to build a
new identity i think the interesting
part for me is going to be at three if
you're not going to get someone like
walker man and this goes back to what
we're talking about connor does that
mean that kayvon thibodeau gets pushed
down even further
does that mean that which is how
hamilton gets pushed down even further
yeah it's absolutely crazy and we're
going to have a long discourse on kt
when we get to the edge rushers because
i think we both know how we feel about
him in this class and where he'll stay
we got to pick up the pace to get there
then let's go
yeah let's let's go let's get to the
comments right now before we move on to
the divisional breakdown and of course
we want to spend a lot of time on the
edge rushers here uh pete rodriguez said
with all the extras due to watson's
legal troubles through the browns hold
on to baker or do you see him getting
traded or released baker mayfield will
not show up to play for the browns even
if they asked him to do a backup role
the problem is
how much with the money he's on the
books for about 18 to 19 million this
year belder it feels like we're running
out of homes for baker mayfield i have
no idea how the situation plays out
besides him landing in seattle which i'm
not even overly confident in that right
now
yeah when when you see people when you
see no one jump into the market at all
it's
kind of
i don't know it looks kind of bleak for
him right like it's like the reality of
it is is like when the panthers didn't
instantly make a phone call or the
falcons didn't instantly make a phone
call after trading their quarterback to
the cults when the saints didn't
instantly make a phone call when the
seahawks still haven't really made phone
calls when nobody's a major player in
the marketplace for you it feels like oh
no what am i gonna do and i think he's
gonna have to
i hate to say humble himself i don't i
don't like saying that i think the
reality of it is he's good enough to be
a starting quarterback in the nfl the
problem is that nobody wants it and
that's going to be interesting to see
how that how that how that shakes out
because
he's a guy that he
people are like you know what i'd rather
take a guy that's you know maybe they're
not doing commercials and just will shut
up they don't want to deal with that
yeah
yeah they don't want to deal with them
so it's that's where it's at you can't
trade for baker mayfield and no forget
the money you can't put them on the
roster and say you're gonna be a backup
so it's created a really interesting
situation uh for his market all right
well speaking of the browns we are
moving on to the afc north divisional
breakdown and obviously
this has been quite the battle this off
season amongst these teams as we pull up
the needs board here you see the browns
they obviously have still quite a few
needs after making the splash move to
land
a future franchise quarterback for them
that they believe in defensive tackle
linebacker they obviously release their
veteran jc treader at center long time
player and they need somebody across
from miles garrett because right now as
we know they have not brought back to
davion clowny yet so edge pass rush is
kind of where i'm going to kick things
off here felder they have picks 44 and
78 right there on day two of the strap
they even have picked 99. so i'm gonna
look at pick 44. you're gonna be out of
range unfortunately for the boye mafes
of the world and pass rushers ahead of
him i'm looking at arnold d bikini a
stand-up rusher
really good hand usage does a good job
of keeping tackles off of him i think he
can flatten the edge i think he's shown
enough ability to counter inside and
this is the player that transferred from
temple was a pretty productive edge
defender there but found
a completely new life at penn state and
turned into
a guy from being a guy to a threat off
the edge somebody you have to account
for that if you leave your tackle
isolated with he can beat you he can
climb into the pocket and make it a bad
day for your quarterback and felder
stating the obvious here whoever plays
across from miles garrett is going to
get a handful of those one-on-ones that
we all love so what do you see any
bikini and what are you looking at for
the browns here in this draft
yeah i think the thing with the bikini
like i i love one you mentioned the
miles garrett point yes if you play
across from him guess what life's gonna
get a little easier but i think he's had
really good coaching and that's the cool
thing great coaching at temple and then
great coaching at penn state two really
good systems to play in that prepare you
for your life after college football to
get to the nfl so i think that's this
that's the start the second part for me
is playing across from garrett this is a
guy that we've seen hands down even on
the clip we just saw hands down
standing up he could do a little bit of
both in his scheme versatility which
means he can run i think he can play
from a 4i to a wide nine which is very
that's that's a big range for people
that don't realize this that's going
from inside outside of the guard inside
the tackle all the way to basically
outside of where a tight end would be he
can do all those things and still get to
the quarterback which means he has the
ability to fit into different uh
packages which makes him dangerous and
so the browns are gonna be excited about
that as well i also think he can rush
from the interior if you kicked him down
to a true four and let him rush from
inside if you bring somebody for his
speed from the outside he can do that
too so i love that for me when i think
about the browns um they need a
linebacker and i go
uh mike rose i look at mike rose from
iowa state and
maybe it's not at 44 maybe it's later in
the draft right third round or fourth
round but mike rose to me
is a guy that was kind of the unsung
hero of this iowa state football team as
someone that started just like brock
purdy just like bruce hall started as a
freshman
and just kept making plays he can play
he plays in a complex scheme a scheme
where they a lot of times have two
downline men uh four linebackers so
that's two plus four is six and then
five defensive backs but they make plays
and he can play in the pass game as you
see right there he can play in the run
game heads up play by the way to quick
take a down take a knee and down that
ball he's not going to waste time trying
to bring it out he knows that this is
going to give us the better feel
position high football iq which is
something i always want to reiterate on
the show when guys have a high football
iq and his ability to play in that
scheme
at iowa state
really lends himself to me to being a
scheme versatile linebacker where he can
play your mic he can play your will and
depending on who you're playing he might
be able to play or sam if it's a sam
that's gonna have to be in coverage a
lot
felder i love that pick i think it's a
value i think it addresses a need and i
think it gives a team that probably
needs an instant starter that exact kind
of guy and when you look at rose he i
thought he would have been a senior bowl
stand out but he was too banged up to
participate in the event so he's been
slept on because he's missed a lot of
this process and you know you're looking
at their picks they are 78 i think they
can get him even maybe at 99. so mike
rose uh maybe not the flashiest kind of
athlete but like you said high
instinctual player that has had a ton of
starting experience that would fit in
with that browns front seven right away
i love that pick all right let's move on
to the ravens as you saw on the needs
card before the ravens have done a
really good job this offseason but they
still have some work to do whether it's
offensive tackle linebacker edge
defensive tackle and that's where i'm
going to start things off because i'm
just looking for them to make a splash
this is a unit that's had the blessing
of clayus campbell for a while over the
years now we're going to go with jordan
davis in the first round felder we're
gonna go with the big boy we're gonna
say you know what we're gonna put him
right over the center the old zero the
old nose nose tackle uh you could
obviously play shade nose as well and
we're gonna say i dare you to run at us
and we're gonna have our pass rushers
get loose off the edge we're gonna flood
the field with with secondary defenders
obviously jordan davis can just
completely remake a run defense and
completely clog all of the space in the
middle of the field so for the ravens
there they love athleticism and they
love size and if you're looking for size
and speed jordan davis is the definition
of that
i mean the fact that he ran that sub 540
at 340 pounds
is insane there are very few humans on
the planet that can do that so what
you're getting is truly a modern a
modern marvel like he's insane at what
he's able to do he's a great scheme fit
because they want a guy that's gonna eat
two in the middle and let linebackers
run they like to play man so what does
that mean he can eat too and then your
safety can spin down to go make a run
play it's very simple what they're doing
but it's very hard to do so you have to
have the specific pieces i love the
addition of jordan davis there i think
that he is i i truly believe that after
the sec championship game he sort of i
think there was a time during the season
where people were talking about him for
the heisman and talking about him for
this and then there was a dip
where
everyone was like he's only played 47 of
the snaps like
get him out of here and
you start to read your own press
clippings a little bit and then you go
into the sec championship game and
alabama's game plan was let's keep him
in the game
let's keep him in
he's not going to hurt us let's keep him
in the game
and
he recalibrated himself in the way that
he played so that he became an actual
force again in the national championship
game against that same alabama team was
able to move and make plays i love that
uh for me i had to double check to see
who i wrote down i got alex wright on
here right he's a developmental edge
rusher from uab
this is a guy can stand up can hand it i
don't i like him standing up more than i
like him with his hand on the ground
he's incredibly fast there's a
twitchiness to him that i really like uh
but you give me you we're i know we're
gonna we're gonna talk about him later
but i think him getting him
i think he
he scratches that itch that baltimore
fans have of
wanting a guy that you know is gonna get
to the quarterback uh a couple times a
game and be incredibly disruptive
yeah felder i look at alex wright and
you just don't get those kind of tools
very often right it's always tough when
you have a pass rusher that's six five
six six long long arms everybody goes
well who's he like and i'm like
these guys don't come around very often
it's just that simple they're just not
built this way right the carlos dunlap
kind of mold where they they have so
much length off the edge but i think the
toolbox uh with him was impressive this
year the variety of ways that he won
wasn't just i'm longer than you i'm
gonna swim over you and then close into
the pocket it's no i can win in a
variety of ways and surprise the tackle
and those gazelle strides to the
quarterback are the difference between
the very nice hurries and hits or sacks
and sacks is how you get paid saks is
the uh the way to close out games all
right let's move on to the steelers
no surprise here we are still looking at
quarterback even after the signing of
mitch trubisky we got offensive line
corner and defensive tackle on there
they have made some offensive line moves
in this early nfl offseason and free
agency
but
i think with this team here you know
we've talked quarterback so much let's
look in a different direction here
felder and talk about their mid-round
picks instead instead of doing the old
kenny pickett malik willis debate that
we've done eight thousand times how do
the steelers get better on day two
listen i'm going for daria bathus i i
love him listen i and you know what
let's you you've got what you've got
pinning right
yep
so you got pinning but let's let's focus
in on mathis mathis to me is
he's so good i mean this guy we see him
he's playing in a shade right here we've
seen him play the five we've seen him
play the four we've seen him do the
three he does a lot of stuff and
like
honestly
when do you think he comes off the board
because
he's active he's aggressive like what's
the gap between him and devonte walker
from georgia
man it's crazy felder that you asked
that because you look at mathis and i
told you this when we were preparing for
the show he's almost become the
forgotten man because
he's a jack of all trades master of none
right maybe he's not
as quick as a perrian winfrey or devante
wyatt maybe he's not as big as travis
jones or jordan davis but when you look
at federian mathis as a three-tech as a
five-tech like you said with 4i earlier
he can handle any of those roles he can
contain the run he can read and react
he's got some juice rushing the pastor
he's not a total dud he's not just i'm
gonna sit here and take a breath and
control two blockers he's gonna try to
get up field as well so
he's a wild card because they're picking
at 52 they're picking at 84. and i think
he's somewhere in the middle there so if
you love the player and you think he's a
starter right away you take him at 52
and you run with that and i brought up
trevor penning to say what if malik
willis is gone what if kenny pickett is
gone right you get punched in the mouth
your plan doesn't go the way you want it
to you're going to roll into this year
and you're going to say we're going to
ride with mr biski how do we maximize
his talent well
there's a good chance that that might be
trevor penning and you see the ability
to climb
move out and get to the second level and
put some bodies on the floor so with
penning i think my questions are that
anchor needs to get stronger but if you
want a tough guy if you want a bully if
you want somebody that plays through the
whistle and has all the traits and has
the athleticism to fit in a zone
blocking scheme penning has that he has
good feet he has good length he has good
forward speed at that size so for the
steelers it's no coincidence felder and
i both looked in the trenches and think
that's how that team needs to keep
building it and get better because
they've gotten really good at the skill
positions we know what they have at
secondary we know that they have an edge
pass rush in a near record setter in tj
y but they still need to keep stacking
the deck to the trenches all right let's
keep this moving and close out the afc
north before we get to the best part of
the show and that is previewing the
loaded edge pass rush group we got the
bengals and the bengals have done
themselves
big time favors here felder because they
added three veteran offensive linemen
and they didn't go to the bargain bin
for these offensive linemen they got
plug and play starters that are big time
upgrades that let's be real
in this draft right now them picking 31
63 95 it's not just the old toss-up
whoever the best offensive lineman is on
the board i'm gonna look at that 95th
pick here and look at jerome ford to
give them some home run speed in the
backfield we know what we have in joe
mixon right joe mixon between the
tackles tough runner we know they got
the ferraris at wide receiver jamar
chase the best young wide receiver in
the league you got t higgins out there
this is a loaded group for joe burrow
but who's the guy that could take the
outside run to the house who's the guy
that can catch the ball and give you the
check down that goes for four yards into
12 to 15. jerome ford's got the vision
we know how important that's going to be
to zach taylor's offense and he's also
got a little bit of contact balance but
right there this is what this offense is
missing b i'm going to sit in the middle
of the field i'm gonna turn around from
three yards and i'm gonna get north to
south i'm not gonna waste time i'm gonna
get north to south and i'm gonna find my
way to the end zone so for a bengals
team that has a lot of pieces and can
afford a luxury pick in a sense i really
like what jerome ford can bring to that
offense felder
well we talked about him already right
he's a home run hitter this guy look
he's run look who he's running away from
yeah okay
he's running away from
georgia like he's running away from them
and i think that's the part that's
interesting is watching the speed like
not just be combine or pro day speed but
actualize speed on the field against
teams against high level competition
guys that are supposed to be faster than
you uh i go listen what are we doing we
got the bengals picking all cincinnati
guys here
because i'm going kobe bryant and i
think he's remarkable as a corner
i think that he is
the top of that second tier of corners
that we have and someone that maybe he
sneaks into the end of the first round
he'll be there in the second round
depending on where you pick but i'm
gonna go bingles kobe bryant because
he's someone who
he can play man he played a lot of man
and look this is him manning up a guy
that we really love george pickens and
you know grabbing the grabbing uh
grabbing an interception like this is
a guy that understands the technique
work and i talked about it when we
talked about uh
bikety right we talked about it with him
as well he's well coached this guy
played for marcus freeman who's now the
head coach at notre dame play for luke
fickle obviously he's still the head
coach in cincinnati he's well coached
well taught understands what he's
supposed to do he plays responsibilities
football he's not afraid to put his nose
in there when it comes to the run but
he's at his best when you don't think
about him when you don't hear about him
when
coming into this year nobody knew his
name
why
because they had sauce gardner on one
side and they had some other guy and
then people started to not throw the
ball at sauce garner so they threw it at
the other guy and they realized the
other guy said don't try me dog i'm
really good and that's why cincinnati
was able to get into the college
football playoff because they had two
quality corners not to mention my main
man brian cook but
he is he's a shut down guy but he's also
a guy that it can be skiing versatile
and play uh some zone as well because
he's not afraid to stick his nose in
there when he has to help with the run
i love it felder kobe bryant one of the
unsung heroes of this corner class that
can probably start for you right away
because when he got tested last year he
did not look out of place so you see the
team needs board there for the browns
ravens steelers bengals uh you see edge
pop up a couple times on this list
and that's where we're going but before
we do let's check in on the ever growing
comment section jay bernatowicz is back
and he said i watch this show just to
admire felder's beard that's the only
reason they got me to do the show so i'm
with you jay bernatowicz kyler lynch
says sorry steelers fans should just
leave already immediately eliminated
from the afc north race that is pretty
brutal all right uh oh no says ravens
taking the north no doubt and then dusty
underscore brown says kobe felder knows
what's up yes he does all right let's
move on to the edge pass rush group we
have been chomping at the bit to go
through this because a lot of these guys
are top 50 picks there's no way around
it they are the cream of the crop of the
draft and we are going to kick things
off with three blue ship prospects and
it's no shock the first one is probably
going number one overall to the
jacksonville jaguars that is aiden
hutchinson he was at the heisman
ceremony he's had an incredible return
after a 2020 season ending injury and
here we are felder aiden hutchinson
expected to go number one overall felder
how did we get here with him
he's incredibly productive and he has a
toolbox
that is
it's full listen as someone who's about
to just got done doing some drywall and
is about to finish painting my toolbox
getting my toolbox out and using it this
guy's got a full toolbox man he's ready
to rock and roll he's got a swipe he's
got a swim he's got a rip he's got a dip
he's got all those things that you want
to have he can rush from the interior he
can bull rush he can do all those things
so that's how he got here
his athleticism
helps check it out obviously there's the
questions about the arm length but when
you're able to do a lot of little things
right it doesn't matter and i think
that's the reason he's
he's the safest pass rusher in the draft
and one of the best
i like where you left that felder
because it's going to carry us to the
next topic i'll chime in on hutchinson
i think with him like you said there's
so much polish that you love that
translates right away and even the
athleticism backs it up that 6733 cone
you see that change of direction that
twitch on film the ability to you know
even get tackles to start to overset and
he started to set them up for the fourth
quarter to beat them inside or just beat
them with straight power with leverage
while yes there are shorter arms and
sometimes he uses it like a t-rex to
advantage to get up under pads and move
guys so for hutchinson
a phenomenal season i do agree he is the
probably the highest floor player in the
entire draft here right now but
highest floor player doesn't always
equal the best player to come out of the
draft and the guy that i think is the
best edge rusher in this draft is kvon
thibodeaux and with thibodeau
it has been this way since i started to
evaluate him as a draft prospect last
june it was hard to miss him when he was
a freshman a couple years ago
this is the real deal here felder the
speed to power the long arm ability the
explosive nature off the snap the
ability to rush wide but when they asked
him to be a bully on the inside and
contain blocks and do a lot of dirty
work he did it and he did it with high
effort he's the kind of guy you want on
your front for
that can handle any rolling you see that
dip and turn that bend into the pocket
that ability to go i'm faster i'm
quicker than you and i'm more flexible
where you're not going to be able to get
your hands on me and we know what kind
of athlete he is that four five eight
forty and that ten yard split uh is in
that 90 percentile territory he's the
real deal felder and i know we love him
on this show
oh you know i love him i mean this is a
guy i've been following him since high
school so
like
hey this guy can play
he's amazing he was the linchpin of
oregon's recruiting class that year he
is someone who just shows up and shows
out and he's been doing it since he was
a freshman uh in cot from a college
standpoint but doing this he was a
freshman in high school as well this
guy's a monster and
i think again i think he can i think he
will be the best pass rusher coming out
of this class i think there are other
guys that are going to have productive
careers i think he's got an opportunity
to be remarkably special which is why i
do keep bringing him up when we talk
about guys getting pushed down based
upon team needs and teams reaching
because
the scariest thing would be if he goes
if he's outside of the top 10 somebody's
going to get an absolute freak like he
is
i'm not going to put him on jadav and
clowny's level coming out of college
because clowney was
a different monster but i think he's a
tier below clowney where he's living in
the atmosphere
um right underneath clowney or miles
garrett coming out of college and i
think that's where he is he's not as
stout in his lower body as those guys
were which is one of my main kind of
causes for concern but when you watch
the speed to power and you watch the
long arm and that long arm that he does
is it's sick it's really it's insane to
watch the way he's able to get that arm
fully fleshed out up against the tackle
to get a six foot six guy on his heels
is remarkable and then walk him back
into the quarterback it's beautiful
football so yeah i gotta go him and then
you know what round out the blue chips
let's go to your guy uh jermaine johnson
florida state by way of georgia by way
of junior college let's get to him
because
as someone who does watch a lot of acc
football he was a revelation for me
yeah he really was i just i'm you know
blown away by his three-down ability the
fact that he showed that he can round
out his past pass rush game whether it's
the swipes whether it's the power he
plays a violent brand of football but
the ability also to set a hard edge and
give nothing against the run i think
that's an area where he's better than
hutchinson and thibodeaux right now and
he's an older prospect he's 23. so he's
had more time to refine that part of his
game to season that part of his game but
you know like i've said before on the
show i've asked him i asked him at the
combine you know really just what
clicked this year and what do you like
to rush from and he was saying when i
got to florida state there was a plan i
was going to rush off the tackle and and
i'm going to give 110 they're going to
get everything i got and that's going to
work and it did for him he was dominant
this year
there is a spin move he put on ikki
akwanu that might be my favorite play of
this entire draft cycle even though it
didn't get the sack it sent the
quarterback running for his life right
through the a gap so i think with
jermaine johnson here felder teams are
going to love that polish and that
violent mindset he brings to the field
every single snap
well the the thing for me with him is
he has to you mentioned that he's older
but he's taking a long road and
sometimes when you take a long road
i'm not going to sit here and say that
these other guys aren't going to
appreciate it more but he realizes that
he could be not in a position to get to
the nfl at all he's taken a long road to
get there
and now he's like i got to seize this
opportunity this is my chance like
you got one shot one opportunity
like he's ready to rock and roll his his
palms are sweaty knees weak arms are
heavy like he's already ready to rock
and roll so i listen this guy's gonna
eat mom's spaghetti when he gets to the
nfl i'm looking forward to it um
let's go you want to go to the next
category we're going to go to the power
rushers because
you mentioned jermaine let's get to the
comments real quick and then we'll hit
the power rushers there was a lot of
love for thibodeau in the comments uh b
wolfy has asked early in the show who's
the most consistent dangerous pass
rusher in your opinion i think you can
tell by me and felder's gospel there
it's kt for us all day uh okay so pete
rodriguez said just imagine if johnson
never transferred that would have been a
scary sight for georgia
that front four my goodness all right um
so we'll go dreams37 here is a great
question who says david ajabo is
definitely a blue chip prospect injury
sucks but i think the ravens take a
chance on him stick around we are going
to get to david jabo at some point
during this preview so the power rushers
and i did see a question very early in
the show about karloftis and why people
have soured on him let's start right
there felder with george karloftis a
player that as you see on the lower
first all big ten
a guy that really knows how to use his
hands really knows how to contain
against the run and has that bull rush
that relentless effort does not possess
the same
twitch that short area change of
direction that we've seen from hutch kt
and even jermaine johnson at times but
somebody that you honestly feel pretty
comfortable putting on the field right
away at the nfl level
yeah he's an nfl player i mean
this guy is strong he's like he
he's so tough and obviously we're gonna
see a bunch of like the highlights from
him but i love how strong he is with his
hands like this guy's
he's a he's a boxer right like he's got
those boxing hands heavy hands that when
he puts him on you there's a shock that
comes with it and then he gets you down
on the ground if you're a ball carrier
or he knocks you out of the way if
you're an offensive lineman i love the
heavy hands that karlath just brings to
the table um one of the
one i might be i'm not sure of the
numbers but he might be the best recruit
that purdue's ever got so this guy and
he lived up to it he was able to do it
the way that he's able to smack off
offensive tackles the way he's able to
get that full extension on a bull rush
and push those guys out of the way so
that he can decide where he's gonna
separate he does all those things really
really well i think i mean he's a first
round draft pick to me and i think that
he is a guy that he comes in and you
don't expect him to be i don't need him
to be a ten sack guy what i need him to
be is a guy that squeezes so that i have
somebody else as a passer specialist to
make plays and a guy that i know is
going to be active in the run game
because there is no fear in him when it
comes to taking on double teams
putting a shoulder into a pulling guard
the ability to squeeze down the hole so
that everything gets easier for my
football team
yeah carlos this was an interesting
background coming from greece playing
water polo growing up he credits a lot
of his lower body strength to that water
polo background and if you've ever
played water polo i had to in gym class
filter yeah you would understand how
dead your legs are after so karloff
that's where the lower body power come
from all right trayvon walker let's move
on to another big time power player i
mentioned it earlier in the show and i
agree it is pretty insane we've reached
the point where it's looking like
trayvon walker future top three
selection in this draft but let's get to
the good this in my eyes is a little bit
of that bowl in a china shop i'm going
to knock everything around going forward
i've got that linear power that straight
those big meat hook hands we saw the
testing at the combine that was
legendary
he right now is a good and will be a
good nfl level run defender whether it
is at 5 tech whether you want to play
him further off or you want to beef him
up and say you're going to play three
tech for us and you're gonna have to
contain
my question here is felder
i've watched all of this tape this year
i don't see a first round pass rusher
right now that to me is a giant risk
with a top 10 pick
yeah i don't i don't think he's i think
pass rushing is something that he's
going to have to acquire as he gets into
the league uh the question for i was
going to ask is what position does he
play because
if he beefs up to play a three-tech he
can't take a three-tech in the top three
that's not gonna happen and if he plays
a five tech you don't usually take five
texts in the top three so that's also
that's also a weird uh position i think
he's a first round player i think he is
he's a he's a football player's football
player he does everything and he does it
with a vengeance and he makes it makes
he comes with bad intentions all the
time and i love that about him but
you saw him even in the clip we just
showed right we saw him light up at a
five we saw him line up at a four we saw
him line up at standing up as an off
ball linebacker and then drop into
coverage there's a lot of things that
he's done
it's just a matter of what do you want
him to do because the nfl is a game of
specialization
and while versatility is value the
reality of it is if you're gonna play in
my front four my front three i need you
to have a thing that you're really
really good at and he still is trying to
figure out what that thing is
i love it felder that's a great way to
break it down it's the fact that if
you're gonna be a top 10 pick you often
need to be great at something and i
think when you pose it with that much
simplicity
that's where it becomes very hard to
justify trayvon walker you know he was a
fun top around two pick for a long time
and now we've reached a point where
you're expecting him to be a superstar
selection and i just don't think it's
there just yet you're projecting him
he's a projection pick another guy that
you know he's built a lot differently
but is absolutely more in that
projection mold is boye mafi coming out
of minnesota where he wasn't somebody
that was going to have a sack every week
he's not somebody that was man he's just
killing our left tackle over and over
again but when you see some of the
traits in boye mafee's game the ability
to turn the ability to be very explosive
off the football the ability with you
know obviously uh to generate power with
his arms and a lot of these are stand up
rush opportunities he's just got that
pop in his hands felder he really can
throw guys backwards and i love the
burst to close on the quarterback and
that ability to constantly you know
you know turn his body in in a sense
that a lot of guys with that much power
often can't do i mean i didn't see that
with karloftis or walker but with mafe a
player with a little bit of a different
build you see that constant hoop drill
on the field the ability to flip his
hips turn his body flatten the corner so
with mafe i think he's going to be a
first round pick the production might
not be there of your common first round
pick but nonetheless an exciting power
player
yeah he's built a lot more like and
let's just put the watt brothers out
there right he's built a lot more like
tj than jj right like he's a little
smaller of a body type
but he's someone if you i think if you
give him the tools to get to the
quarterback he's got an opportunity
and
it's interesting that he fits into the
power rusher category because when i
watched him i always was like
he does play hard and he does play
physical
but he wins the most of his wins come
with speed but he plays every play with
this physicality that gets the job done
so he's an interesting prospect to me
i there's no doubt in my mind and this
goes back to kind of the theme of the
show right where
he's gonna get picked above somebody
that we probably like more than him
because they think they can turn him
into
a pass rush specialist the guy that can
get to the quarterback and i think if
you pair him with somebody else a more
experienced pass rusher now i think you
you've got something and whether that's
like you what is it the bill's traded
for von miller and you have him
with a guy like a von miller where he
can understand i just think that the
coaching wasn't there for him to
understand the best ways to get to the
quarterback all the time and i think
that's a that's his next step he has the
speed he has the power which is why he's
in the power category and he just has to
figure out the route the move the
counter move to set up guys to get to
the quarterback so that's going to be
interesting for him
all right harvey jarvis jumping in the
comments getting in on the conversation
says mafe will be better than walker i
think they're definitely very different
players but nonetheless yes not the
craziest take i've seen around alonzo
soto loved the
eminem
bit alonso soto also said mape should be
a second round pick any way you see him
slip into the first uh i think boya mafe
is going in the first round just to
prepare everyone here
and then e callahan 4 asks this fellow
of all the rushers who has the fastest
jump i'm assuming that means get off the
ball
we're going to get into some of those
guys with the speed rushers category and
obviously the blue chip guys they're
calling card is getting off the snap but
let's take things
to the speed rushers right now and start
with somebody that you brought into i
think the very first episode of draft
crash course of the year felder give me
the gospel on oklahoma pass rusher nick
benito
yeah nick benito listen we'll talk perry
and win for you later but like nick
benito to me is
he's the dude he's to me he's the
ultimate dude off that defense this guy
is explosive he's fast he is a stand-up
guy i don't want him with it i don't put
his hand down let him just rush from the
top you see it there all speed like all
killer no filler he's gonna get around
the edge you watch him here coming from
a little bit from the interior to move
and then get down line to be able to
make a play he's able to do a lot of
different things he is
he
conor he is at his best when people
don't get their hands on him and you see
it right there there's a relentless list
to his game where he's gonna work
through it but the best thing for him is
making sure people don't touch him that
much that's when he gets to the
quarterback as you see right there in
that clip against iowa state his job as
a pass rusher is making sure people
don't touch him so that he can get to
the quarterback to me that's the epitome
of what a speed rusher is
yeah i think you perfectly summed it up
there felder everybody just saw hassan
reddick get about 45 million dollars
from the eagles in free agency nick
benito plays a very similar game it's
i'm going to stand up i'm going to beat
you with speed you're not going to be
able to get hands on me and i have
enough athleticism to twist and turn
into the pocket change angles and even
cut inside at times all right moving on
maije sanders who is coming off a very
good pro day in a sense that he got his
weight back up to 247. maje was below 2
30 at the combine i believe it was due
to an illness maybe a stomach bug but
felder he's back an easy 20 pounds back
on maize sanders and most importantly we
like what we've seen from this guy on
film with mahje to me felder the calling
card is
getting off the football he is always
the first guy off the snap the ability
to
basically dictate and see it right there
you don't stand a chance when you're
that fast off the football he's gonna
dictate the play and what i mean by that
is he's a step ahead of the tackle the
guard and they need to figure out how do
i redirect how do i recover this guy is
just too quick for me
playing for a cincinnati defense that
was a dominant unit he was the dude up
front
yeah my dad's not going to be thrilled
about the ecu clips because they my both
of my parents went to east carolina so
not going to be thrilled about that but
at the end of the day when i look at my
jay he is
i i love watching him play and people
are gonna talk i've heard people already
talk about his lack of production or his
total stat numbers here's the reality he
played in a defense
where they told him go as fast as you
can to get to the quarterback and then
we'll deal with it after
and so what he does he's someone a lot
of times you'll see defensive ends
you'll see linebackers in blitz packages
you'll see guys break down right you'll
see them break down and then try to
mirror the quarterback and get to the
quarterback under control but cincinnati
said let's go get him go get him now and
then when he has to change direction we
have a safety valve that's why our line
that's why they have what they have
three guys with over 100 tackles because
the whole goal was to push people and
disrupt the play so he can be incredibly
disruptive um he's not as powerful as a
guy like a dante fowler but he has the
disruptive capabilities of him because
of that speed so he'll blow a play up
and you know what he may not get a stat
for that play but what he is going to do
is
spill that play to the linebackers spill
that play to a safety coming down and i
love that part of his game something
that doesn't always show up on film or
doesn't always show up in a stat sheet
but he has it in spades
yeah it's a great call felder and for
the nfl fans at home watching you're
looking at defenses necessarily like the
49ers like the new york jets like
seattle like dallas that they tell their
front four and especially my j sanders
off the edge
get home
get up field and we'll worry about the
rest we're not asking you to sit we're
not asking you to read and react we're
not asking you to contain we're asking
you to be the first one over the line of
scrimmage and force people to move and
then the rest of the play will flow to
the second level defenders so there's a
lot of defenses fell during the nfl that
that translates to that maiji sanders is
going to find himself a home i think at
least in the first three rounds but we
might be looking at the second round for
him all right let's round out the speed
rushers here talked about arnold evac
katie earlier on the show for the browns
here felder uh we obviously did a pretty
full breakdown on him but felder what
did you notice from a guy like eva cady
that was a good player at temple and
turned into a great player at penn state
i think it's all coaching and it's it's
it's it's pointing guys in the right
direction and that's not to take away
like he's got great athleticism he's got
great instincts he has all those things
good football iq but i think the
coaching in in putting him a guy that
they they can use you see him here
standing up recognizing let's widen him
out one step so that he's able to gain
leverage on a tackle let's widen him out
a little bit you see him here look at
how wide he's playing and playing that
wide allows him to get a better angle to
get to the quarterback understanding
that aiming points here you see him hand
down but he understands how to let this
guy go to the next level in that run
game again more widened out you widen me
out now you're worried about me being
out wide i can get inside here and i
think that's the key for him it's it's
where you play
so if that means over the course of a
game whoever drafts him you start him
out at a nine or you start him out at a
seven and you have him coming wide wide
wide which is what he's very comfortable
doing then you move him to a six and
that tackles still worried about him
coming wide now he can get to the inside
and i think that's the part where his
usage is critical and that's where his
speed comes into play so that's why i
like ibukity is so much he's he's he's
so useful as a piece because of his
ability to rush from wide but then get
back inside
all right love it felder looking at the
comments here mcat 93 says this
defensive class is stacked watch out i
know we agree pete rodriguez says where
do you see benito getting drafted second
or third round i think he'll be an early
third round pick get on the field as a
situational pass rusher right away and
then maybe over time he rounds out his
game as an early down defender and
felder dreams 37 and you watch these
guys from high school all the way to the
nfl so i'd love your take on this dreams
37 says these defensive ends have gotten
bigger and faster this is a solid
defensive end class for this year's
draft
yeah man i mean i'll be kt uh caitlyn
thibodeau amazing uh the best guy that i
think i've ever seen like in person as a
high schooler is probably chase young
and
i'll never forget going out there to
watch chase young play and i mean he had
the he looked like the predator and
one of the coaches
that was running drills goes this dude
is a predator he's a he's a great white
apex predator nobody can beat him and i
was like okay got it taking your word
for it oh you played at miami you were
you were a defensive end at miami got it
you know what you're talking about
fantastic so yeah this is this is great
i know we got another group of guys to
get to uh before we wrap so i'm excited
man like this is this is a really good
class and
good class had multiple rounds too
because we talked that we hit on the
blue chip guys we hit on my j my j
the idea that he might sneak into the
back end of the first round for a
contender
that should be terrifying to people
because
if you use him or bonito as your
dedicated pass rush specialist
you're going to get results
yeah felder said it this is a loaded
group i mean from this show alone we had
to cut out uh players that we love
whether it was
kingsley and igbarre d'angelo malone uh
sam williams those guys are all going to
be top 100 picks and you know we got to
keep this thing moving we can't be here
all day as much as we'd love to be so
the developmental edge rushers let's
start with the guy that's been in the
news lately obviously unfortunately
heard at the pro day david ojabo felder
before we get into the player himself
just set the scene of what was
uh truly heartbreaking to to watch
somebody that
you know has just had a marvelous year a
marvelous process everybody loves him as
a person and you watch him go down at
the pro day
not the best look for the scouts running
the pro day but we do know that jabba
will be back and and better than ever
shortly yeah it's it's just
to watch him go down obviously uh
rupture achilles
uh to watch the
to watch one of the scouts running the
drills go pick up the football and walk
right past him while he's on the ground
screaming obviously we want michigan's
training staff to get there quicker it's
one of those things that kind of speaks
to the cold nature of football right
like you've there's guys that go down
i've seen dislocated kneecaps i've seen
obviously dislocated shoulders and you
move the drill up and you just keep it
going but it's one of those things where
for him in this moment a guy who seemed
to be a first round lock and may still
be a first rounder to go down with one
of the most gruesome injuries that you
can have with respect to football it is
it's brutal and you see him here he
could play standing up and i connor i'm
interested and and so we've touched on
the injury we know that's going to set
him back a little bit i'm interested to
hear how much do you think of his
production was rooted in playing across
from hutchinson and how much is him
still continuing to learn the game of
football because he is in our
developmental category because he's a
young football player
yeah i think it's a fine balance right
felder he falls in the developmental
category for me because
michigan will be the first to literally
show you they didn't want him on the
field early downs against the run but
when it was time to eat on passing downs
you see the spin move there
he's like a shooting guard trying to
take the ball to the hole the stutter
steps the spin move just different ways
to get into the paint
where that are very finesse related but
translate because he's that fast at the
next level so with the jabbo i think
what you'd like him with him is to get
stronger in his lower half now he's got
a rehab process to go through that's
gonna hurt that for his rookie season of
the nfl but can in year two can he get
thicker and stronger in that lower half
while still having out that pass rush
game that is so predicated on beating
the tackle around the outside shoulder
the spin move the stutter step to get
inside and those one-on-one match-ups i
mean felder let's call it what it is
he's not that number one right he's not
the the chase young the thibodaux even
the hutchinson he wasn't on his own team
but when you have a guy like a jabba
with that kind of speed across from him
somebody's still going to take him in
round one for a lot of reasons one the
untapped potential is insane from him a
foreign-born player that has come over
here with not a lot of football under
his belt and has been a star on the
field and has really thrived in that
program as one of the dudes of that
program and then the fact is you want
that fifth year option if you're a team
picking in the first round because you
want him there for at least five years
because this won't be a redshirt year
but it'll be a rehab to developmental
year hey if we're a contender the kansas
city chiefs will get you on the field in
the postseason on third downs
no i i love it i i i think it's
interesting i'm glad you brought up the
basketball analogy because uh one of my
favorite football players of all time
and i think he's
probably one of the top 10 defenders of
all time is julius peppers and julius
peppers also had that and i'm not saying
jabba's julius peppers julius peppers
obviously was a top three pick like what
i'm saying is that stutter step and that
basketball translation to the football
side where you're doing a crossover
essentially you're bringing allen
iverson on to the offensive you're
basically crossing over an offensive
lineman and ojabo has that i haven't
found a way to describe it so i
appreciate you kind of shedding a light
on that for me because i hadn't thought
of what it was but that's the quality
that i really like about him is the
stutter step and he he we talked about
it with uh with bonito right he's at his
best when he doesn't let you get hands
on him and i think that's that's a
that's a capable quality that's
something that's repeatable results
all right moving on to a player in drake
jackson from usc that i think came to
the program with expectations to be in a
future top 10 pick conversation felder
and unfortunately it just it didn't get
there he had instant success i think or
flashes as a freshman and a sophomore
and then this year
while he was a good player and
definitely falls in the mix of that
speed slash developmental i think he's
very twitched up i think he's another
guy that can cross you over a little bit
the rest never fully came together
felder whether it was the lack of power
whether it was the lack of variety of
ways to win i think with drake jackson
he's somebody that everybody wanted him
to be a premier player and right now
he's still a work in progress
yeah it's frustrating um
and
listen i know i'm sure there are usc
fans that are watching and i don't
there's no disrespect
i just don't think that this was a very
tough football team in general and i
think he's a victim of that as well um
or a product of that if you will where
there's just
i wanted to see him put paul's on in
bulrush a little bit more walk somebody
back use that long arm that we talked
about with k von thibodeaux i wanted to
see more of that from him he's
remarkable uh you saw even in the tight
package that we just showed you see the
spin move you see the swim you see a rip
you see the inside the outside to get
inside you see all these little moves
these good setups i just wanted him to
be i wanted him to play tougher stronger
and
i think that's
a usc situation not a hymn situation
and
it goes back to you know who else is in
that room and
i like he would have benefited from
someone like a leonard williams being
there right someone who's going to play
tough play strong football body people
up size him up but he didn't have
anything like that when he got there and
so the big part the big question for him
is gonna be continuing to explore how
tough he can be continue to explore just
being like rough and tough like let's go
man let's get crazy so i think he's a
really good player i think he's got all
the traits that we're looking for i
think he's got moves and some counter
moves that are really fun to watch i
think it's just about him
wanting to go out there i want to see
him put his hand down a little bit more
first of all and then second of all i
want to see him go out there and just
grab up a tackle and walk that tackle
back into the quarterback i want to see
more of that
yeah he's got the body type to do it
it's just not on film as as much as you
would expect with him all right to round
out the developmental rushers then we'll
get to the comments before we say
goodbye we're looking at alex
rightfelder this is a name you brought
up earlier in the show i kind of threw
the carlos dunlap at you the long arms
the long slender build
he really exploded this year and it was
kind of funny you know i remember him
flashing in 2020 but this year looked
like a player that
it just started to win in a variety of
ways he's got the length to swim we know
he can rip
he's got some power in that big body but
when he gets across the line of
scrimmage those gazelle strides lead to
sacks with alex wright so you had him
earlier in our show elder you've been
high on them what are you saying
yeah i love that you call them gazelle
strides i mean this is a guy where he's
what was he gonna take here one two
three four five and he's all the way to
the other side of the field dragging a
guy down like he
when he like it only takes him a handful
of steps to get to the quarterback and
there you see him playing with a little
bit of power which i don't think i think
is underrated about his game because
he's not afraid to set the edge and this
is against tennessee coming out of uab
setting the edge against tennessee is
good stuff he's got this ability to
make up ground very quickly and i love
that about him uh we didn't i know we
didn't on that package we didn't have
him hitting the hump running the hump a
little bit but i mean we're talking
about a guy that's going to take four
steps and now he's at the quarterback
there is no there's not a choppiness to
his game it is long strides it is a dip
it's a rip and then i'm there and i love
that about what he's able to do so alex
writes interesting watching a lot of uab
obviously he's well taught their defense
as a whole over the last few years once
they resurrected their program well
taught so alex wright goes in the list
as well he is someone i think that the
opposite of drake jackson right he plays
bigger than he is
and i think the key for him is going to
be to learn some of the drake jackson
stuff which is
not just all power and setting the edge
but also let's get some counter moves in
here my man
and drake jackson's got to pick up some
of that alex wright power so if you can
combine these two now we get that what
is it alex drake jackson right now we
got a player
yeah you're all over it felder it's
funny comparing my notes side by side
with him that i just pulled up and with
right it's he wins with the push pull
wins with speed to power and of course
with drake we were kind of talking about
the opposite wins the corner wins the
spin move wins with twitch in that
crossover mindset so that's why these
guys are in the developmental pass
rusher category let's check in on the
comments before we get out of here on
the spine thursday
uh austin scott 117 says best overlooked
edge i'll go with d'angelo malone a
little bit in that nick benito
undersized speed rusher good bend edge
felder is there somebody we didn't get
to today that you want to give a shout
out on the show
no i think you're spot on man like we
like look people don't realize this but
like we start emailing
literally we will email about this show
starting after this show for next week's
show and so we had to cut a bunch of
guys out but it's just one of those
things where
it's a time thing we've already gone
over
yeah i mean we're way over right now we
get to as many as we can
shout out to the comment section it's
been awesome interacting with you guys
week after week i see a lot of familiar
names in there which means i think you
like the show which we appreciate and we
will be back next thursday with another
episode of draft crash course every 1pm
eastern time in the bleacher report app
i'm connor rogers he's stadium's college
football analyst michael felder catch
you next week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]